vous souvenez-vous de la première fois que vous avez vu un
dinosaure pour les enfants qui grandissent en aimant les
dinosaures, les films jurassiques sont vraiment
le moyen pour eux de voir leurs rêves
réaliser que les films jurassiques ont toujours
été pleins de suspense et passionnants, nous
racontons le prochain chapitre de cette
histoire  dinosaures et emmène Jurassic là où
il n'est jamais allé auparavant
ou fait littéralement exploser l'île
dans ce film nous avons un nouveau réalisateur
Juan Antonio
Bayona  aux
gens effrayants mr.  X dinosaures prudents
partout et ils s'effondrent et
tuent des gens allons-y, il était important
pour nous que l'histoire soit équilibrée sur les
personnages dont certains que nous connaissons et
dont certains rencontraient juste Jeff Goldblum
ne va pas mentir c'est assez génial Ici
je  je parle à nouveau de dinosaures dans ce
monde drastique, vous verrez plus de
dinosaures que vous n'en avez jamais vu auparavant
dans ce film, nous avons affaire à de vrais
dinosaures animatroniques, il ressemble à un
vrai dinosaure, je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
paniquer tout le temps
le défi de  faire une suite, c'est
trouver le bon équilibre entre ce que les
gens attendent et ce que les gens
seront surpris par
ce film est différent ça va être
intense et gratuit
spectaculaire c'était mon meilleur jeu
c'est comme rien que vous n'ayez jamais vu
auparavant
ouais mec c'est jurassique
ça va être génial